wir sind auf der suche nach
außerirdischen leben einen riesenschritt
weiter gekommen die nasa hat mehr als
700 neue extrasolare planeten entdeckt
werden wir dort aliens finden jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction
es ist ein neuer rekord und ein
meilenstein auf der suche nach
außerirdischer intelligenz
715 neue exoplaneten so viele wurden
noch nie in einem jahr entdeckt 2014 ist
damit das jahr der exoplaneten die
zentrale frage aber ist gibt es dort
leben die planetenforschung ist noch
eine relativ junge disziplin denn erst
anfang der 90er jahre wurden die ersten
planeten außerhalb unseres sonnensystems
entdeckt bis dahin gab es schlichtweg
keine methode planeten zu finden und es
wäre theoretisch sogar möglich gewesen
das ist gar keine planeten außerhalb
unseres sonnensystems gegeben hätte mit
der entdeckung von drei planeten die um
dem pulsar psr 12 57 5 12 kreisen durch
den polnischen astronomen alexander john
wurde das 1992 anders der pulse nämlich
unregelmäßig der planeten seinen strahl
blockierten durch genaue bestimmung
dieser unregelmäßigkeiten konnten drei
planeten mit 0,02 4,3 und 3,9 erdmassen
entdeckt werden es waren damit die
ersten planeten die zweifelsfrei
existiert 1995 wurde dann der erste
planet der um einen stern ähnlich
unserer sonne kreist entdeckt planet 51
pegasi b kreist um einen stern im
sternbild pegasus seine entdecker hatten
festgestellt dass der stern 51 pegasi im
alle herum eiert verursacht durch einen
planeten der um ihn kreist man hat der
stärke dieses 1 konnten sie sogar die
größe des planeten errechnen 0,46
jupitermassen so langsam kamen die
besucher in fahrt jetzt ging es darum
planeten aufzuspüren die erd- ähnlich
sind und damit leben ermöglichen es war
wie die nadel im heuhaufen zu suchen die
meisten planet waren so heiß zu kalt zu
klein zu groß es gab kein wasser auf ihn
oder sie kreisten zu nah um ihr
zentralgestirn doch in den letzten
jahren wurden immer mehr planeten
entdeckt und damit auch immer mehr auf
denen leben möglich ist eine bedingung
ist die entfernung der planeten zum
stern um den sieg reisen sie müssen sich
in der sogenannten goldlöckchen zone die
heißt wirklich so der habitablen zone
befinden benannt ist diese zone nach dem
märchen über das goldlöckchen das zuerst
zu heißen brei ist das land zu kaufen
und dann breit er richtig temperiert ist
denn das ist die wichtigste bedingung es
darf auf dem planeten nicht zu heiß und
nicht zu kalt sein damit leben entstehen
kann und es gibt planeten auf denen
diese bedingungen gelten und auf denen
sogar ausreichend wasser vorhanden ist
allerdings sind das nur sehr wenige ließ
12 14 w ist einer von ihnen und
vielleicht derjenige mit den besten
bekannten lebensbedingungen er hat den
richtigen abstand zum zentralgestirn
einem roten zwerg also einen kleinen
nicht sehr heißen stern und gis 12 14 b
verfügt über eine atmosphäre mit einer
menge wasserdampf hier sind die chancen
am größten das leben dort existiert
allerdings ist ließ 12 14 b rund 40
lichtjahre von uns entfernt für uns zur
zeit unerreichbar doch es werden immer
mehr erdähnliche planeten entdeckt bei
den jetzt gemeldeten 700 extrasolaren
planeten sind immerhin vier super erden
dabei das heißt gesteinsplaneten mit
mehreren erdmassen mit erdähnlichen
bedingungen die chancen jetzt wirklich
leben auf diesen super erden zu finden
stehen gar nicht mal so schlecht die
rechnung der wissenschaftler ist dabei
ziemlich simpel erstens sie gehen davon
aus das leben unter optimalen
bedingungen entstehen muss und zweitens
um so mehr erdähnliche planeten es gibt
desto größer sind die chancen dass auch
ein planet darunter ist mit optimalen
bedingungen dort also leben entstanden
sein muss wir können also gespannt sein
welche planeten noch in zukunft entdeckt
werden und wann wir das erste mal ein
beweis für außerirdisches leben finden
was meint ihr werden wir aliens finden
oder sind wir ganz alleine im bereich
wird es in diesem jahrhundert den ersten
kontakt geben oder ist das unmöglich
diskutiert dass in den kommentaren mehr
zu klicks science fiction gibt es in
einigen szenen gründe für ihre existenz
oder das letzte video so funktioniert
youtube und so nutzt du es so wie du es
willst galileo war gestern hier kommt
ein update 2.0 clixoom science und
fiction abonnieren oder probieren und da
oben gehts zum blog ja und dann ist nach
links und da gibt es nicht
viel anders